so I'm just gonna introduce myself I'm
Kate white I'm coming to you from the
University of British Columbia Canada
and actually I'm gonna be kind of
changing gears a little bit in terms of
what we're talking about and so what I'm
gonna be talking about is encouraging
individuals and residents to engage in
sustainable behaviors like recycling and
I admit that my title is probably the
longest one on the list so it sounds a
little bit complicated but it's actually
a really simple idea and so the idea is
that if we can match elements of our
messaging so that they're congruent we
can actually make the information easier
to process we can make it easier to
understand and making it easier to
understand makes it seem like it's
easier to do and the good thing about
that is when it seems easier to do
people are more likely to do it and so
that's what I'm gonna be talking about
today okay
so in terms of getting people to do
sustainable behaviors things like energy
conservation recycling there's an
important challenge and so the challenge
is that usually what we're asking people
to do is something that's sort of some
kind of a cost to the individual self
so it's either inconvenient or it takes
time or it's causing me to change my
behavior as an individual and the payoff
is kind of more general and it's for
others and it's for the future so we're
asking people to take some kind of
individual level immediate cost to the
self and the payoff is for sort of
others or for the future so it's hard to
get people sometimes to make these kinds
of trade-offs and so that's that's
really what I'm interested in studying
and that's where I'm coming from with
some of this research and so I actually
did this research when I was at the City
of Calgary so there's the city of
calgary in case you didn't know that's
what it looks like and basically what
they were doing is they were introducing
a new residential recycling sort of
curbside recycling program and they've
done some tests some sort of market
testing in certain quadrants of the city
and they found that people were pretty
good at complying pretty good at doing
the recycling behaviors but they weren't
quite as good as they had hoped and so
we are finding some sort of pockets of
resistance
and they didn't they sort of had done
some test communications where they kind
of did that an informational campaign
about this is recycling this is what you
do here are the steps and they weren't
really finding that not everybody was
really getting on board and so City of
Calgary asked me to help them figure out
a way to sort of how do we get these
people on board okay and so when I
started looking at was actually
something called message framing and the
idea behind message framing is that
there's kind of two different ways you
as a communicator can frame a message so
the first one is a loss screen message
so a loss is a loss frame message is one
where sort of the negative consequences
of not engaging in the behavior or
highlighted right so if you don't
recycle these are all the negative
things that will happen a gain frame
message is one that talks about what
will be gained if you do recycle so what
are all the positive consequences of
engaging in the behavior so what are all
the positive consequences of recycling
and people interested in behavior change
look at this quite a bit so health
psychologists things like that there's
been a lot of work in loss frames versus
gain frames but when I looked at
research on conservation behaviors so
things like water conservation energy
conservation there seemed to be some
mixed results so sometimes the research
said lost frames work best they're more
motivational you should always use a
loss frame other research said no no no
gain frames work best and so it was a
bit is a bit confusing and so what we
wanted to look at is well maybe it
depends so maybe sometimes lost frames
work better and sometimes gain frames
work better oh I don't know I keep doing
that sorry guys um and so what we wanted
to do is look at a moderator and a
moderator just means it depends on
something else and we looked at this
theory it's called construe level theory
and it's actually kind of a simple idea
so the idea is that there's two
different ways that people can view the
world so the first one is
a concrete way of viewing the world or
inactivity so something like recycling
so what concrete mindset is one where
you're thinking very specifically about
the lower level details of the behavior
or the activity so when you are thinking
about coming to this conference today
the sort of concrete thoughts around
coming to this conference today where
things like what will I pack how will I
get my flight
what talks will I go to so sort of the
details the how of what you're gonna do
when you're at the conference on the
other hand the other way of sort of
thinking about it could be more abstract
so abstract has to do with higher level
thinking thinking in more general terms
so in terms of coming to this conference
today you might have thought about well
I'm really excited about learning more
or bettering my education or integrating
my experience so those are more general
thoughts about the activity in terms of
coming back to the domain of recycling
what we thought is that there's two
different ways
residents can think about recycling so
the first is a more concrete way so
thinking about the details so how will I
organize the bottles how will I take the
labels off when will I put it out those
are the details the concrete details of
recycling the other one is abstract so
thinking in a more abstract mindset so
why will I recycle what's good about it
why should I do it those are more
general thoughts about recycling and so
what we think is actually that if you
match the frame so the loss or the gain
to the right type of mindset you can
actually encourage consumers to process
the information better and to make the
activities seem easier to do and so we
think that losses themselves so thinking
about a loss frame actually puts people
in this sort of action-oriented very
concrete type of mindset itself so it
makes you think about the details and if
you compare the lost frame or sorry you
can pair the lost frame with this more
concrete type of mindset it's actually
gonna work really well so we're
basically just saying match it match
messaging in a way that puts sort of the
concrete thoughts with a concrete way of
thinking with lost frames and it's gonna
be more effective at getting people to
do these behaviors on the other hand we
think that game frames put people in
sort of a broader level of thinking they
make them think more abstractly and so
sort of similarly if you compare a gain
frame message with more of an abstract
appeal this is gonna be more effective
in getting people to do the behavior and
so what we did is we did a field study
with the city of calgary and this was
with their residential recycling program
so there's the cart basically the ideas
you put your materials in the cart and
you have to wheel it down to the curb
and they get taken away for recycling
and what we were able to do was an
experimental design and so what we
varied was the mindset or the construal
level that was being sort of primed in a
marketing message and the marketing
message was presented in the form of a
door hanger the door hanger was
recyclable material and and fully made
of recyclable materials so we didn't
seem like we were being inconsistent and
so it either had a very concrete message
or an abstract message and I'll show you
those in a second and then we also
paired it with either a lost frame or a
gain frame the other thing we had was a
control group so the control group was a
group that got nothing so what happens
if they get no message at all and so
this is kind of what it would look like
so people either got the concrete
focusing on the how do I recycle what
are the details or they would get the
abstract message so wide of your cycle
thinking about the broader context and
then that was either paired with a lost
frame for a gain frame and so the
overall view of how we did this as we
went in at the first the first week and
we did a pretest of recycling behaviors
so all that was is it men be getting an
army of research assistants to help me
and actually looking in people's
recycling bins which I'll tell you what
we look for in a second which actually
isn't as bad as it sounds the bad
was getting up before the trucks come to
pick up the recycling they start at 6:00
a.m.
in November and Calgary being on the
street at 5:00 a.m. is not enjoyable
just in case you're wondering so we did
the pretest of recycling behaviors week
1 week 2 we delivered the marketing
materials and then week 3 we went back
and we went and looked in the recycling
bins again and recorded the same
measures to sort of see how did these
change over time after we implemented
the different messages month 6 went back
again one of our reviewers when we
submitted our research said hey why
don't you guys go back six months later
and see if it continues over time and
we'll see I'll show you how it worked
out at the time I was kind of mad at the
reviewer but I'm okay now I'm okay so
okay so what did we measure so that's
sort of what a typical bin looks like
and there's some logistical issues with
doing this so we had to think of some
certain things and so most of Calgary
has most of the households have back
alleys and it's kind of hard to tell if
they're putting out their recycling or
not because everybody's recycling bin is
just sitting there so what we have to do
is choose a neighborhood where it was
clear if they were participating or not
and so we chose a neighborhood where
they would actually have to roll it out
to the front yard so we could tell if
they are participating or not and we
chose a neighborhood that wasn't too
inner-city because we didn't want to be
the case that homeless people might be
going into the bins and taking certain
objects out we really wanted to try to
get an accurate measure of really what
are people putting in their bins and are
they following instructions and what
kind of materials are going in so there
were some logistical issues to think
about in terms of what neighborhood we
chose and these are the things we
measured so the first thing we measured
was participation and so we coded this
at different time points obviously so
basically did you put your card out or
not it was the measure of participation
the second thing we measured was volume
now volume was tricky because kinds of
ethical issues we weren't allowed to go
in and
of way or sort through and dig into
people's recycling but we did develop a
way to kind of measure the volume and so
what we did is we created a measuring
stick that was sort of a height of the
bin and we used that so whatever the
height was we had like a pyramid
calculator and we could kind of
calculate what the volume was of
materials that were going into the bin
we asked ethics if we could take
pictures they wouldn't let us so then we
tried to get other ways in but that's
how we had to do it the other thing we
measured was following instructions so
the City of Calgary wanted consumers or
residents to do certain things and they
weren't really following instructions
very well so the bin has to be a certain
distance away from the household the lid
has to be closed and it has to be
pointing in the right direction or the
truck can't pick it up so we sort of
checked off to see whether or not people
were following these instructions and
the last ones variety and variety was
tricky because we couldn't necessarily
empty the whole bin but we could have a
good we could move our stick around have
a pretty good peek so and the variety
was based on what the city cared about
so they had five categories so they had
glass they had paper and cardboard
aluminum missing one glass and then the
other one is actually beverage
containers so things like milk
containers and drink box containers they
have as a separate category and so they
really wanted to encourage the sort of
fold breadth the variety of recycling
okay
so what did our messages look like so in
the coffee construal condition it was
all about how to make a difference so
the tagline was think about ways to make
a difference and these are all the
details so these are the things you can
recycle one of the big problems is
putting mixed materials in the bin which
means it's a product that's made of
maybe plastic and cardboard and you
can't recycle that unless you take the
pieces apart and then you know just the
details about how to do it and when to
do it and the abstract construal
condition it was all about why dat why
to make a difference so think about
really
to make a difference so it's sort of
this higher level why should we be doing
this so recycling will save our precious
air land and water resources recycling
contributes her community so much more
general statements about why we should
be recycling and then on the other side
of the door hanger there was either the
loss or the game so the loss frame is
think about what we lost in your
community if we don't keep recycling and
then these sort of statements we're all
lost frame so things like by not
participating in the blue car program we
waste over sixty thousand tons of paper
we don't recycle we will lose over ten
thousand school buses full of plastic
they were all sort of what will be lost
if we don't recycle the game frames have
the same information so think of what
what will be gained in our community if
we do recycle but they were all
positively framed so we will save over
sixty thousand tons of paper or we will
save over ten thousand school buses of
plastic so just different framing of the
message so why don't we find so these
are the measures of participation and
they're coded for an increase so a
higher number means an increase in
participation over time and so if we
take a look
pairing the loss with the help so the
messages that we think are gonna
activate this more of a sort of a
concrete mindset or sort of focusing on
the details pairing those two together
works quite effectively more so than a
control condition and these mismatch
conditions over here also the game and
why together seem to work really well at
encouraging residents to engage in the
behavior more so than the control group
and if you look at the mismatch
conditions so the loss why and the gain
how they they don't perform any better
than the control group either
so this is volume so how much material
were they putting in the bin and the
patterns the same so the match of the
loss and how works particularly well the
match of gain and why they're not
significantly different although
sometimes it looks like they might be
those two seem to work the best and
they're more effective at encouraging
residents to put more products or more
material in their bin and the control
and then the conditions that are
mismatched you're gonna get the idea so
a variety so putting in a variety of
different products or materials into the
bin the match of loss and how and the
match of gain and why works particularly
well whereas the other conditions so the
mismatch conditions lost why in the gain
how are about as effective as a control
group just about as effective is not
giving a message at all following
instructions same thing so the match
works best so the loss with the help and
the gain the gain frame with the Y works
better than other conditions okay here's
the really interesting thing so I
mentioned this the the six month later
the follow-up and we did this for all
the measures I was a little bit
disheartened with the reviewers said
that because I was thinking I have to
get out my naps I have to figure out the
routes it's probably not gonna work I
hoped it would work and it actually
helped pretty nicely and so this is just
a measure of volume but we did go and do
all of our measures and it was sort of
the same pattern for all the measures
and so what we found that over time so
the first bar is time 1-9 time - so the
three weeks later and the second bar is
time one - time three which is six
months later and so what you can see Oh
what you can see is that the lost hell
sort of held over time in terms of
people and the in the volume that they
were putting into the recycling bin and
the gain y really held overtime so more
so than the control condition and more
so than the mismatch conditions
so a couple of things
it seems that having a match in terms of
messaging seems to work really well and
it works across all of these different
measures the other thing we did is we
included a measure of what people that
are interested in recycling call
contamination and contamination is
throwing things into the bin that you
shouldn't be and one potential
explanation is well you increased in
volume in certain conditions but how do
you know they're throwing the right
things in there maybe they're throwing
in things they shouldn't be and there
were certainly things in there that
shouldn't been there so people were
putting in tools and toilet seats and
kitchenware and just things that
shouldn't be there so we did record that
as well and so all of our results hold
when controlling for contamination and
we find that having the the match and
messaging actually reduces contamination
so people are more careful about what
they're putting in there okay so we did
a second study and this time what we
wanted to do is is look at our
manipulation of this idea of control
level so the concrete in the abstract in
a slightly different way and so there's
research that suggests that if you're
thinking about something that's really
close in the future like right now
you're gonna be thinking more concretely
more about the details but if you're
thinking about something that's coming
up in the future
started far off in the future it's more
likely you're gonna be thinking about it
abstractly and so there's quite a bit of
research that supports this what we
wanted to do in this study is manipulate
this idea of concrete and and abstract
by using time so are you focusing in
more on the near future or are you
focusing further on into the the far
future the other thing we wanted to do
is use a more simple and more controlled
execution of the framing so you might
have noticed that the some of the
wording was a little bit different
across conditions with the City of
Calgary example and so in here what we
wanted to do is really have very
controlled manipulation so you can't
explain it in terms of the different
wording it really is what we're what
we're manipulating it's the closed
versus far or the the concrete versus
abstract and it really
is the gain in the loss frame and so
here's what we think we think that the
loss frame message is gonna really work
well when it's framed in terms of
something closer to you so focusing on
today and we think that the gain frames
gonna work really well when it's
focusing on a time point that's further
away so focusing on tomorrow so here's
what we did this time we used
undergraduates and we manipulated two
things so the one thing we wanted to do
was make it close in time or foreign
time and then we wanted to either do the
loss or the gain frame and the time
manipulation was just a very simple
statement so they saw it they saw an
advertising proof from the city of
calgary and the tagline either said
recycle for a better calgary today or it
said recycle for a better calgary
tomorrow so a very straightforward
simple execute execution and the other
thing that we did was we had had a
different message for a manipulation so
think about what will be gained if you
recycle or thinking about what will be
lost if you recycle and this time what
we measured was recycling intentions and
so things like this so how likely are
you to use the city of Calgary's
recycling program how inclined are you
how willing are you and so here's what
we found so in terms of the loss free
thinking about it more proximally so the
closed time point seems to be more
effective in encouraging more positive
intentions but but if you look at oh I
just got technophobia today if you look
at the gain the gain frame it works much
better when it's focused on the distant
time point and so once again we get this
matching effect so losses work better
when it's more concrete gains work
better when it's more abstract the last
thing I wanted to do is try to figure
out what's going on and so what we think
is going on is something that
researchers call fluency and it sounds
kind of fancy but all it means is
it's easy to understand so we think that
matching the message makes it easy to
process it makes it easy to understand
and the interesting part of this is we
think that making fluency higher so
making it easy to understand actually
makes it seem easier to do and
psychologists like to call that efficacy
but it just means I think I can do it I
think I can impact change through this
behavior and so basically making a match
in terms of messaging makes it seem
easier to process easier to understand
making it easier I understand makes it
seem like it's easier to do and then I'm
gonna be more likely to do it or more
likely my intentions are gonna be higher
to do it so in this study we used
undergraduates again cuz we wanted to
get in and look at sort of the process
of what was going on and they actually
viewed the same appeals that were used
in the City of Calgary study so the
other saw that same gain your loss frame
and then they either saw the more
concrete or the more abstract message we
also included some measures to assess
this idea of fluency and so these are
ones that have been used before in the
literature so is it difficult to process
or easy to process is it difficult to
understand is it easy to understand is
it difficult to comprehend or easy to
comprehend and then we included some
measures of efficacy so I feel like I
know how to go about recycling I believe
I know what steps to take so I feel like
I can do this and I feel like I
understand how it works and then once
again we include the measure of
recycling attention and so here's what
we find
so with similar pattern again so if you
look at the the how messages
oh and and the why message works
particularly well with the gain frame
once again and then what we do this is
we wanted to go and look at sort of
what's going on in terms of driving
these effects and so this is what we
actually did in the paper
I'm not even to talk about it
because it's it's a it's you know it's
the structural equation modeling we're
not gonna talk about that we're just
gonna go back to this so the idea is
with mediation analysis what we found is
that we find this sort of pathway we're
making a match does seem to make it
easier to understand and it seems like
from the statistical analysis making it
easier to understand does impact making
it seem easy to do and then making it
seem easy to do does impact these
recycling in these are recycling
outcomes so I think it's kind of an
exciting finding because just making it
seem sort of conceptually or mentally
easy to do who makes its or easier to
process it makes it actually seem easier
to do okay so some of the conclusions
obviously it's interesting that there's
this interplay between messaging and
control levels so law streams seem to
work best when they're with these more
concrete or sort approximately closed
messages gain frames work really well
when there were these abstract or sort
of distant messages in terms of time and
the really exciting thing I think is
that making it easier to understand
makes this thing easier to do it's a
simple message and it's something I
think could be done in a lot of
different context with different types
of messaging um so why is this useful
one of the interesting things I think is
that this worked with a field study with
real behaviors that it held six months
later so this idea of this idea of when
you get people to engage in a process it
can have positive consequences
downstream
I think this carries over into this from
be the previous presentations as well
and if you think about it when you're
coming home from work there's a door
hanger on your door you're holding your
groceries you're grabbing your kids
you're picking up the mail there's all
these things interfering with what
you're doing and probably not everybody
looked at both sides of our door hanger
and read it really carefully and but we
still got the effects so the fact that
we can get these effects in the real
world I think is pretty exciting
so obviously one of the implications is
match the
healed the marketing message and this
doesn't have to necessarily be in the
domain of recycling so in Canada we have
quite graphic smoking labels on our
cigarette packages I don't know if
you've seen them some of them are a
little disturbing most of them are lost
frames and part of this is because the
Government of Canada mandates what type
of information has to be on those
packages or on those labels and it has
to be about health consequences and the
health consequences of smoking are
negative so they're all very lost framed
messages and so it would suggest that as
a communicator if you know you have to
communicate a loss frame message you
might want to pair it or put it in a
context where you're also getting people
to think about the details about the
concrete aspects of the behavior or of
the situation making it easy a process
can make it seem easy to do so anything
in your marketing materials or in terms
of pairing messages if you can make it
easier to understand it might make it
seem easier to carry out the behavior
the other thing to think about is
whatever you're asking people to do if
it's a behavior change type of activity
if you can match the timing to the
message that can be effective too so if
it's something that you want people to
do right now a very concrete message
might be more effective so I want you to
go vote tomorrow perhaps a more concrete
message is going to be more likely to
drive them to action if it's something
further down in the future it might make
more sense to match your messaging with
more of an abstract appeal so that it's
sort of more fluent in terms of how
people are thinking about it so whole
future research one thing I mentioned is
that I don't think this necessarily has
to be in the context of recycling it was
a nice context first to look at it in so
I think that similar kind of matching
effects might emerge for other behaviors
too so I mentioned health change that
kind of thing
one question is would it work as well
for more unfamiliar behaviors so
obviously we all know how to recycle
it's pretty common it's nice that we can
get some movement on people's recycling
behavior
but what about things that are
unfamiliar or that we don't know as much
about and so one of the things I'm
working on right now with the City of
Calgary something they call grass
cycling anyone heard of it oh I'm
impressed couple and it's kind of an odd
term but it's an interesting idea and so
what the problem is is the city seems to
get these sort of spikes in terms of
garbage disposal and one of the spikes
is Christmastime there's all the food we
eat and all the extra packaging all goes
into the landfill
the city kind of says well I don't think
we can we can sort of tackle
Christmastime but the other big spike in
consumption and then disposal is the
summer and it's a different type of
disposal what it is is it's actually
yard waste and the problem with throwing
yard waste in the landfill is that it's
compostable it sort of naturally
regenerates itself but what we're doing
is we're throwing into the landfill
we're covering it up making it get no
oxygen and it's just sitting there for
much longer than it really needs to be
and so what the city of calgary wants
residents to do they're calling it grass
cycling so what people in calgary tend
to do is they tend to have big lawns
they tend to mold along they tend to
break up all the grass carry put it all
in a bag carry the bag to the back curb
and and sort of put it into the landfill
and so what the city of calgary wants
residents to do is mow your grass and
just leave the clippings on the lawn so
it's interesting cuz they're actually
saying usually with these behavior
change things we want people to do more
work but this time we were like no don't
rake up the grass don't put it in the
garbage bags don't put it on the curb
don't do it and they sort of launched an
informational campaign trying to get
people to do this idea of grass cycling
and nobody will do it so they're very
very hesitant to do it and the big
problem is what will my neighbor think
right of all my neighbors are breaking
their lawns they're making it all look
pretty no one else is doing this grass
cycling thing right why should I be
doing it and so what we're looking at
now is is for doing messaging around
norms so what does everybody else doing
and what does everybody else think I
should be doing and trying to match the
messaging there so
yes why because inside a of grass I
cleaner so I'm just kidding
can we get kind of similar effects in
terms of other behaviors too so
questions yep see any sort of messaging
to take transit or anything about
sustainability about transitory other
cars into transit to benefit so ours our
research would suggest just in your
messaging try to make things sort of
congruent so for getting people to
change maybe if it's more of a
short-term focus like try it tomorrow
right you might sort of focus more on
these losses or if it's a long-term sort
of focus think of the future then you
might sort of do more of sort of
matching with a game frame might be
something I'd recommend yeah and on the
grass I think how did how did you get
underneath what was preventing people
from just ignoring the grass clippings
was it a survey and the way we measure
grasscycling is kind of fun it's even
more fun than looking in people's
recycling bins we actually follow the
garbage truck and the garbage collectors
they're pretty good at feeling it
knowing what's in the bag they kind of
signal what's in the bag so I have my
research assistants they're following
the garbage trucks and the garbage
collectors are really nice about helping
us because we pay them with beer so it's
off the record not on the job but so we
did do we did do market research and
that's what really came out is we're
really worried about what other people
think that was one of the the top
reasons that came out yeah so in this
increasingly political season it's hard
to imagine that game versus loss
messaging hasn't been extensively
studied in terms of correlations with
wondering if you know might be very
interesting to look at yeah I don't know
but that does sound very interesting
well I'm at risk of at risk of throwing
political stereotypes you're there is
there's this perception that Nanyan
liberal versus conservative that it's
that liberals tend to to focus on the
promise of the future and you know what
can go right about the future and
conservatives tend to focus more on what
can go wrong and I'm wondering if it
seems to me there must be some church or
Cambridge
well I think you're some themes right
but I don't know just gonna be dominant
but it sounds like it would work
sounds interesting yeah strong
literature in big games then actually
says even brain overweight negative
information 3 to 4 to 1 over positive
and if you think about it as an adaptive
behavior for us a thousand year 2000
years ago dealing with threats was much
more important than doing the positive
just a quick question
if you did research with other than
undergrads but you did it with adults
I'm wondering whether or not the longer
term is you might be differently
weighted the whole concept of
intergenerational discounting right
doesn't seem to have a strongest way
with undergrads yeah I mean I think
you're right so when we think about time
as we get older the way that we think
about that can differ so you think do
you have an intuition about that do you
think it might be stronger that's that
for adults anything that's more than
four or five years out it's just kind of
complicated zero okay
that's why we still drive cars get on
airplanes and spoil it even if
graphically we know we're destroying its
life I don't know if that particular
study would vary by age but it's an open
question yeah Oh cultures that
haters that are actually quite
complicated composting process might
help war question right we know how to
recycle we might need a little bit of
information about what what counts what
doesn't count
but you're right composting is maybe
more complicated so the question might
be what it would the sort of the he'll
be really important and the loss be
really important I I don't know yet so
that's a good possibility
forgot to I have to say thank you